hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the Paul
Morphy saga the first American chess
congress is finished and here we have a
very interesting game it's Charles Henry
Stanley against Paul Morphy Charles
Henry Stanley is the first official
United States Champion he became United
States Champion in 1845 so two years
before at the happening of the first
American chess Congress and here Morphy
is challenging him to a duel with well
with the odds of a pawn you can see that
Murphy's F seven point is missing which
is not a small thing to to offer the the
first official United States Champion
and he became like I said in 1845 here
we even have a a nice image of this when
he defeated Eugene Rousseau of New
Orleans so let's just enjoy that for a
second and yeah it's quite the game
after the first American chess Congress
Murphy before returning from from New
York to his at his South in New Orleans
he decided to make use of his time and
place some more games he decided to
challenge the members of the New York
Chess Club either to uh to a match
Morphy against everyone
then he when they declined then he said
okay he will maybe challenge them and
give them odds of a pawn and the move
and pretty much everyone refused this
this offer except Charles Henry Stanley
here he accepted the offer on on behalf
of the New York chess club and so the
match started the mat the the idea
behind the match is first to seven wins
and this is a game five not all of the
games were safe from this match and
first I didn't think if I was going to
show the match or not but then I saw
this game and I thought that we should
really show it as well it just features
the most unusual mate so without further
ado let's check it out we're not gonna
discuss any theory since Murphy's f7
pawn is missing Boone really makes sense
so II for by Charles by Charles Henry
Stanley we have b6v for more fee goes
Knight to f6 attacks d4 pawn Knight to
c3 and now II 6 so if more feet does
everything perfectly for example there's
a pier Knight here let's say this he
somehow gets to the lights per brush
minute game
castles he will be down upon but he will
have a semi-open fr for his rook so it's
not all that all that's terrible but if
on the other hand white plays extremely
well then it's just a pawn down so
Bishop to d3 white continues development
Knight to c6 now putting pressure on the
d4 phone and the blush of the e3 Stanley
defends it with E 5 by morphe and here
comes d5 grabbing more space in the
center with knife to e7 by morphe
switching the night over to g6 and now
h3 not allowing the g4 square for
amorphous pieces we have Knight to g6
and now Knight c2e2 it's a quite quite
an interesting idea as this Knight
already came into play but he wants to
move it to make room for the for the C
pawn as he is expecting more fita at
some point challenge the center with
would see c6 but maybe some other moves
were were a bit more you know maybe
finish development first but ok he goes
a knight c2e2 and now as the g2 point is
undefended morph immediately goes for a
knight to h4 so the g2 pawn hangs Kings
the f1 is is a fine move but Stanley
decides that the defendant would rook to
h2 and this is already a weird move
we have gush up the e7 by morphe g3
kicking away more fees knight Knight to
g6 in the now f4 so make sense as you've
prepared it with g 3e Capra's on f4 by
morphe we have Knight captures on f4 and
the now comes Knight to e5 morphe not
interested in trading he just improves
the position of his Knight
we have Knight to f3 and now morphe just
castles and here there's a general
principle and says that says when you're
when you're better material wise or
position wise you should trade down and
you know the more you trade down the
better you will be
however here it doesn't really do
anything for white but Stanley still
goes for a nightcap resign e5 pawn
captures now you have to move your knife
somewhere doesn't really have a lot of
good squares you have G 2 e 2 and E 6
but this will just double your pawns
well double your WL e pawns so instead
he goes Knight the
- but now more he takes this opportunity
to attack the white center with c6 and
although he's still down upon
he definitely has compensation because
white white slights where there's a
business all the great than the knight
and recurrent really doing all that much
the king is still in the center of the
board
so morphe definitely has compensation
for the pawn and here you wanna just
continue developing you wanna ignore
this c6 move you have to admit that you
have to give back the pawn nothing to be
done there play Queen e2 Castle
queenside maybe and hopefully take the
game from there however he wanted to
defend everything he played c4 but this
just will not do here more if he finds a
very nice reputation he plays Bishop to
b4 with check and okay now you have to
defend obviously we're not gonna go to
the F file in front of the rook so you
have to block it so Bishop to d2 was
played but now comes Queen to b6 by
Murphy and okay it doesn't seem all that
bad
again you can develop maybe the Queen
and into Castle queenside perhaps you
can still survive this however Bishop
captures on b4 was played here Thompson
is a Serena Thompson Stanley is hoping
for Queen captures you block with the
Queen and you're doing okay you're still
up upon and you should be you should do
well in the endgame however morphe had
something else in mind so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
well different idea that morphe played
well i give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on not being greedy and
going for the bishop and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show its
Knight captures on e4 and now all hell
breaks loose as the knight is hanging
the rook is hanging but you cannot
capture either because if if you capture
the night then Queen to f2 is mated the
rook of course defends the Queen and f2
but if you capture the rook then Queen
Queen to f2 is still made because now
the the knight guards the f2 square so
here is Tenley has to figure out what to
do here he goes for Knight to f4 he
gives back some material to close off
the F file from the rook and also now
the rook guards the F 2 square so he's
hoping now for captures the knight and
then maybe he can he can survive
but morphe goes of course for Queen to
g1 with Czech and now he's just gonna
pick up the rook King e2 we have Queen
captures on h2
King to e3 and now Queen to f2 with
Czech we have King captures on e4 morphe
sacrifices the night and now this is
basically the reason why I'm showing you
this game feel free to pause the video
and try to find a win for morphe it's
actually a forced mate in 5 so you know
have at it while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on this
spectacular mate in five and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook captures on f4 with check
point being if you capture the Rope
Queen captures is mate and if you don't
capture the rook then the King has to
start his march up the board and then
it's a king hunt Queen checks King has
to go up the board you check up the
board check of the board and now you
don't have Luke to f8 mate but now comes
the unusual mate we were talking about
you just move the bishop and it's made
for example the ship captures on h3 and
it's mate or g4 or f5 for that matter
doesn't really matter but the rook from
a eight actually delivers checkmate so
that's that's the the unusual mate we
were talking about however the reason
why I'm showing you this game is because
morphe didn't go for row captures on f4
instead morphe went for Queen to b4 with
check and probably a case of morphe just
instantly playing like he did like he
did it against paulsen and now he allows
King to f3 so now the king who goes out
and it's unclear how are you are
continuing the attack sure you can grab
the night but then you lose the rook so
you don't have infinite material here so
what happens here more if you decided
first to go for c5 first save the rook
and then you're gonna decide what you do
here but the problem is Bishop the c3
comes with an attack on the Queen and
now the next move is pretty much forced
rook captures on a four by morphe with
check g captures and now Queen captures
on f4 with check King to g2 and now
morphe has no more ways of continuing
the attack so he has to continue to
happily sacrifice pieces bishop
captures on h3 he needs to bring the
rook into the game and fast we have King
captures on h3 only good move if you
don't do it then then it's it's very
good for black
so King captures on h3 now Queen to h6
check King G to Queen g5 check and here
Stanley is reluctant to go to the F file
not to allow rook to f2 or look to f8 to
check so instead he goes back King to H
to here more if he played Queen to h4
with check and it was in this position
on move 29 that they agreed to a draw
now it's interesting that a draw was
agreed upon because white is actually
winning here but Stanley doesn't want to
take his chances against Murphy and on
an open board with his King taking or
taking a walk because this is game 5 and
Stanley lost the previous 4 games and in
fact after this game Stanley resided the
match even though it was first the 7
wins he said ok that's that's just
enough I lost for now ok I drew one but
not not really proud of this draw the
point is that was Tenley actually can't
play this after King here like the Queen
g5 checking if - not f1 you should keep
the keep away from the first rank and
now after look to f8 now you hide King
t1 not kingi - if kingi - you're getting
made it after Queen G - check King III
now comes Queen f2 check here and queen
f4 is made so you have to go to one and
then finally after Queen g3 check you're
gonna go kink the detail look f2 check
and finally King 2 c1 and you've you've
escaped everything and now you can play
this game where you are just up to
bishops but Stanley didn't feel like
like testing if he could win this and he
wanted to well basically he was he lost
the previous 4 games and he didn't want
to lose another one and he wanted at
least a draw against morphe before the
the match ends I forgot to mention
Charles Henry Stanley also took part in
the first American chess congress but he
was eliminated in the first round when
he played against least an hind more of
his opponent more one of more fees
opponent also from the first American
chess Congress and here before before I
forget
we already mentioned in the previous
video that morphe did not accept any any
cash prices and here the price for the
match or well the stakes were $100 each
so morphe of course he won the match but
he refused the money so instead he gave
the money he won he sent it the
Stanley's wife to mrs. Stanley and not
he didn't give it to him he gave it to
his wife because well as Lawson mentions
in his book more if he thought that
Stanley would just wasted on booze so
instead he sent it to his wife more if
he knew that Stanley's wife was pregnant
and that she was you know due to give
birth in some maybe two months and he
wanted her to have the money so he sent
her the money and later Stanley in honor
of Paul Morphy named his daughter
Pauline so very very nice story also one
of the reasons why I decided to show
this game to mention that as well and
here I have something very interesting
these are all the games so morphe played
during his visit to new york in 1857 so
let's just check it out you can pause
the video print screen' it or you know
save it if you wanna there are a lot of
games aside from the first American
chess congress he also played a lot of
friendly games a lot of games at odds a
lot of blindfold games there's also a
consultation game so there have it
underlay under left even games under
right games at odd so for example you
can see that he played on the left
against Louie Paulson at even games
eight wins one loss and three draws like
we know it from the first American chess
congress but then at games a lot you can
see that oh it's a QN that I believe
that's a Queen's night so he gave him
odds of a night
Murphy was still able to win seventeen
games against Paulson lose nine and draw
three at the odds of a night
that's that's pretty crazy but yeah
that's just in case you want to check
that out
and also you can see that there's a
there's the match on the left also where
is it morphia versus shorten 24 games
were played 23 wins by Murphy and the
24th game was was lost by Murphy
probably again you know just intoxicated
by the 23 0 more Murphy had
to mess something up you know as usually
does but yeah that's also one of the
things I wanted to show you guys so we
are finished with New York morph we
spent there some three three and a half
months and he decides now to go back to
to New Orleans and we are we are gonna
take a continue our story from there in
the next video so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it once again
congratulations everyone who found that
forced mate in five I would like to
thank very much Murdoch Alya
Tasos our own Patsy's Julien boy smart
and Reuben barb Ellis for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday